la situación es muy tensa en la blusa
después del ataque armado que causó la
muerte de dos jóvenes israelíes en dos
hermanos Uno de ellos de 16 años en una
carretera de la ciudad si jordana de
jugoara esta ruta es una de las pocas
usadas por colonos israelíes que
atraviesa una ciudad Palestina de ahí
que con cierta frecuencia se registran
en esta zona agresiones tanto de
palestinos contra fuerzas o colonos
israelíes así como ataques de colonos
contra propiedades palestinas enjugara
detrás el tiroteo las fuerzas israelíes
han cerrado los accesos anablus y grupos
de colonos han convocado marchas algunas
con llamados a tomar represalias de
hecho ya se ha registrado el incendio de
al menos dos viviendas palestinas y la
media luna roja reportó que un palestino
fue apuñalado varias veces por colonos
lejos de calmar los ánimos el Primer
Ministro israelí Benjamín netaniagu dijo
que la respuesta de Israel es atacar el
terrorismo con fuerza y lo ejemplificó
con la pena de muerte para quienes
Israel considere terroristas una
propuesta aprobada de forma preliminar
en paralelo a este ataque en la luz en
el texto debe pasar otras cinco
instancias antes de convertirse en ley
pero propone aplicar la pena capital a
responsables de ataques mortales contra
israelíes motivados por racismo odio o
para dañar el estado de Israel de
aprobarse esta normativa que apunta
principalmente a los atacantes
palestinos significaría la
reinstaudación de la pena de muerte en
Israel luego de 60 años todo esto
mientras en una cumbre en Jordania
delegaciones de Israel y la autoridad
Palestina acordaron desescalar la
violencia en el terreno y volver a
reunirse el mes que viene en la ciudad
de egipcia de Sharon